so what if
that's the reason we're lucky is that we
got to have a rare cascading
of um like an accelerating cascading
effect in terms of the complexity of
things
so like
maybe most of the universe is trying to
get sticky with the memory
and it's not able to really form it and
then we got really lucky in that and it
has nothing
like there's a lot of earth like
conditions let's say
but it's just you really really have to
get lucky on this
but i'm doing experiment i'm doing
experiments right now in fact
experiments that sarah and i are working
on because we have some joint funding
for this where we're seeing that the
universe can get sticky really quickly
now of course we're being very
amphicentric we're using laboratory
tools we're using theory but actually
the phenomena of selection
the process of hydrogen developing
heterogeneity
we can do in the lab we're just seeing
the very first hints of it and
it wouldn't it be great if um we can
start to pin down
a bit more precisely
um beginning becoming good bayesianists
for this for the origin of life and the
emergence of life to finding out what
kind of chemistries we really need to
look for
um and i'm becoming increasingly
confident we'll be able to do that in
the next few years make life in the lab
or make some selection in the lab
from inorganic stuff from sand from
rocks from dead stuff from moon wouldn't
it be great to get stuff from the moon
put it in on our origin of life
experiment and make moon life
and restrict ourselves to interesting
self-replicating stuff that we find on
the moon
uh sarah what do you think about this
approach of engineering life in order to
understand life so building life in the
in the machine yeah so
i mean lee and i are trying right now to
build a vision for
a large
institute or experimental program
basically to do this problem but i think
of it as like
we need to simulate a planet so like the
large hadron collider was supposed to be
simulating conditions just after the big
bang lee's built a lot of technology in
his lab to do these kind of selection
engines
but the question you're asking is how
many experiments do you need to run what
volume of chemical space do you need to
explore before you actually
see an event and i like to make an
analogy to one of my favorite particle
physics experiments which is super
kamiakande that's looking for the decay
of the proton so this is something that
we predicted theoretically but we've
never observed in our universe and
basically what they're doing is every
time they don't see a proton decay event
they have a longer bound on the lifetime
of proton so imagine we built an
experiment with the idea in mind of
trying to simulate planetary conditions
physically simulate you can't simulate
origin life in the computer you have to
do it in an experiment
simulate enough planetary conditions to
explore the space what's possible and
bound the probability for an original
life event even if you're not observing
it you can talk about the probability
but we hopefully
life is
not exponentially rare and we would then
be able to evolve
in an automated system
alien life in the lab and if we can do
that then we understand the physics as
well as we understand what we can do in
particle accelerators so keep expanding
physically the simulation
the physical simulation
until something happens yeah or just
build build a big enough volume of
chemical experiments and evolve them
just say volume you mean like literally
volume i mean uh physical volume in
terms of space but i actually mean
volume in terms of the combinatorial
space of chemistry
so how do you nicely control the
combinatorial exploration the search
space
such that it's always like
you keep grabbing the low-hanging fruit
yeah how do you build a search engine
for chemistry
well we should carry on doing this i
should pretend the physics be the
physicist you'd be the chemist no so the
way to do it is um
i will always play a joke because i i i
i like writing grants um uh to ask for
you know money to do cool stuff but and
i years ago i started wanting to
build so i actually wanted the weather
so i built this robot in my lab called
the computer which is this robot you can
program to do chemistry
um
now it's a pro i made a programming
language for the computer and made it
operate
chemist chemical equipment
um originally i wrote grants to say hey
i want to make an origin of life system
and no one would give me any money for
this they said what is ridiculous why
are you wanting to make oh it's really
hard it takes forever you're not a very
good origin of life chemist anyway why
would we give you any money
and so i turned it around and said can
we you can instead can you give me money
to make robots to make molecules are
interesting and everyone went yeah okay
you can do that
uh um
and that's so actually the funny thing
is the computer
um project which i have in my lab which
is a very briefly it's just basically
it's like literally an automated test
tube and we've made a programming
language for the test tube which is cool
um
um has come as literally came from this
i went to my lab one day said i want to
make a search engine to get the origin
of life because i don't have a planet
and i thought about doing in a
microfluidic format so microfluidic is
very nano
very small channels in device where you
can basically have all the pipes
produced by lithography and you can have
a chamber maybe say between say 10 and
100 microns in volume and we slot them
all together like lego and we can make
an origin of life system and i i could
never get it to work
and i realized i had to make do
chemistry at the kind of
test tube level
and what you want to be able to do yeah
yeah it goes back to night that tweet
1981 1981 the computer we're looking at
a tweet from lee in 1981 the computer
was a distant dream
and oh wow this is the scientist looking
back it is
the young boy who dreamed in 2018 it was
realized spelled in a british way
realized um
so now there's a system that does the
physical manifestation or whatever the
programming language
um
the spec
tells you to do yeah when 1981 i got my
first computer zx81
what was the computer zx81 zx81
sinclair zx81 it was um and i got a
chemistry set
and i like i like the chemistry set and
i like the computer and i just wanted to
put them together i thought wouldn't be
cool if i could just use the computer to
control the chemistry set
and um and obviously that was insane and
i was like you know
eight years old right nine years going
on nine years old and um and then i i
i invented the computer
just because i wanted to build this
origin of life grid
right which is like literally a billion
test tubes connected together in real
time and real space basically throwing a
chemical die dice throw dice for a dice
for a dice you're gonna get lucky um and
that's what we i think sarah and i have
been thinking very deeply about because
um
you know there's more money being spent
on the
the the origin of
the gravity or looking at the higgs
boson and the origin of life right and
the origin of life
is the i think the biggest question or
not the biggest question it is a big
question let's put it that way
you